alors la cure cette école ans mon frère
y boit trop n'en trouve pas j'ai bossé
martin justement là il n'ya juste de
rentrer de thalasso là mais oui oui ça
lui a fait du bien il est devant moi là
est comme neuf je suis amoureux tu veux
que je te dise qui va se passer
tu vas l'avoir d'accord actu va penser
que les sauver tu va casser des murs ta
mentor a l'impression d'être vivant
puis les jours vous passer des trucs
marcheurs et moins en moins bien
et toi tu sortiras de moins en moins dix
ans
tu vas voir c'est vachement bien foutu
ce truc parce que tu seras exactement
quand passer à quelqu'un d'autre
il marche le regard fier mais or au même
mois devant lieu derrière mais avec là
je me sens et si je la fais quoi là
voire 100 ans ils me suivent pas à pas
je ne leur échappe par mes hommes mais
sommes tous d'amour et de tendresse mes
amants
vous faites une forteresse mais sommes
tus rime avec thé sans nom bon pas mais
d'autres en fait ca unis touché trop
jeune pour moi il son bilan quelques
fois mais hommes mais homme et tout le
monde va à paris moi je me retrouve seul
et ça et ça tout le monde s'en fout pas
moi je m'en vais la santé ce mobile
homes maisons